to celebrate the 1 000th episode of my
show my producers have come to me with
what i think is the stupidest idea
they've ever had they came to me and
they said michael to celebrate your
1000th episode we've got to mark all the
crazy things that have happened over the
years and so we want you
to do a video reacting to videos of you
that you've done over the years
which is
the plot of inception i think which is
so
unbelievably navel-gazing and
preposterous and self-indulgent i said
no until they told me they thought it
would get clicks and so i said okay
that's fine i live to serve that's what
we've been doing these past 1 000
episodes thank you to everyone who has
made it possible to go on now for 1000
episodes of the michael knowles show and
so i will tamp down my own tastes i will
indulge my self-indulgent producers
this video is brought to you by ring we
will get more from them in one second
first though
let's get to the first video
chazz chop also known as soy maglia in
vegas whalia and the soviet union
it is no more good lines
will last forever for generation unto
generation we will take a look back at a
few of the funniest home videos from the
capitol hill autonomous zone and select
this is a retrospective of a
retrospective wonderful
beautiful art of the jazz
here it is
this is just another
wall of our art our
our expression of our feelings
i had completely forgotten about the
chats the capitol hill autonomous zone
during all the blm stuff it's just
crazy
especially when you think of a thousand
episodes of doing a show that at least
begins with the daily news how how
moments that were so intense that were
so it seemed like it was life or death
the future of our country depends on
this it seems as though that the
rapidity at which these life or death
moments blm trump the impeachment the
first impeachment the second impeachment
the ukraine trump had a phone call with
ukraine all of these all of these events
it's like the news cycle they just get
us all ginned up
and then
they move on okay what's the next club
wow university of missouri kansas city
[Applause]
a lot of gender bending in the crowd
that woman is wearing a shirt that just
says
it's very difficult to use my platform
when people use the heckler's veto to
try to shut up any opinion that
disagrees
i didn't think i was this intimidating
that poor guy never saw it coming the
guy he busted in the fire door and then
sprayed me with whatever whatever was in
that super soaker and but he didn't
realize there was a cop right behind the
door
so by the time i i feel something hit me
and so i square up on the guy and
by the time i turn on him that cops
already got him on the ground and he the
kid looked up at me with this expression
of just sheer confusion
because he didn't think he was going to
have to pay any consequence for going in
and attacking a speaker at a public
university
he was just shocked i'm really glad that
my reaction when the guy sprayed me with
the thing was to turn on him it would
have been really embarrassing if i had
you know turned away or
cowered down or but the only regret i
have is i wish i had pulled a george w
bush and kind of ducked it
maybe that's for the next thousand
episodes all right
i'm asking the question so hold on a
second um hold on a second yeah i'm
asking the questions
feel free to try to control it but you
won't get through it
i'm not one of them i'm asking you what
can be done about climate change i'm
pretty ignorant about the whole argument
myself i'll admit i'm asking you what
should we do i've answered this five
times no you haven't you're the reward
that i did you were rewarded i feel so
excited for you i feel so badly for you
it's very easy to play a victory
you can do all you want to i don't
everybody
and i just want to say clay you're
probably the worst moderator i've ever
seen in my life asking very dishonest
yes or no questions but anyways that's
perfectly fine
the weird thing is i was supposed to
debate chris hahn
in reality
chris was basically the moderator of the
debate clay aiken decided he as a
moderator was going to debate me the
whole time and it did not turn out very
well for him i would say it turned out
about as well as his stint on american
idol where he lost
we'll get to more on that in one second
first though you got to go to ring.com
michael with summer coming up i am going
to be traveling quite a lot i'm always
traveling quite a lot and who do i trust
when i do that i trust ring you know
about the ring video doorbell
it's amazing technology you keep an eye
on your home from anywhere you know
about ring alarm i hope you know about
rings alarm well now do you know that
you can go pro
yes rings award-winning alarm system
with available professional monitoring
can now let you go pro what does it mean
to go pro it makes such perfect sense i
can't believe no one had thought about
this before you want to protect your
physical home you want to protect your
doors and your windows and everything
from the bad guys and the freeze and the
fire and the flood obviously but we live
a lot of our lives online now and so you
got to protect your digital home as well
cnet calls ring alarm pro a giant leap
for home security protect your wi-fi
protect your data protect the physical
home and the virtual home okay do all of
that especially this summer when people
are gonna be traveling having a good
time get that piece of mind get that
professional monitoring go to ring.com
michael that is
dot com slash m-i-c-h-a-e-l
all right next one
about two weeks after my
eighteen-year-old i wasn't sure this i
didn't make an appointment at a planned
parenthood clinic because at the time
there wasn't as many clinics as there
are now
um so i had to actually travel to
another state to go to a planned
parenthood so you you went into planned
parenthood you said i am identifying as
a boy i think that i'm a boy
did they say okay well you've got to go
talk to some therapists for some period
of months or years or did they say here
here are the pills lady go here are the
pills sir go have go have a good day
pretty much here it's not even pills
it's injections um here are the
injections sir
this was in a pretty amazing interview
because i had not heard of this young
woman before helena kirschner and
someone sent me a sub stack piece that
she had written on transitioning as a
teenager and then detransitioning right
and so i read her piece
she's pretty interesting i bring her on
for an interview and she was not not
really well known at all so we do do
this interview i was astounded we went
way over the time that was supposed to
be allotted for it and the thing goes
totally viral pretty quickly and all of
a sudden this girl becomes a
pretty big face of the detransition
movement she's good on camera she's
articulate but she told a compelling
story but it's more i think even beyond
the interview itself it's that
people know that
they just know deep down no matter what
the experts tell you no matter what the
lab coats and the geniuses with the phds
and everything no matter what they tell
you people know that boys are not girls
they know that pumping little kids full
of cross-sex hormones is probably a bad
idea they know it's going to lead to
regret
we know we're going to look back on this
in 20 years and actually we're going to
look back on it already and we're seeing
some of that regret you've got the
social phenomenon parents are so eager
to help their kids if they're sexually
confused
now all they're ever being told is
affirm your kid and his delusions chop
off his body parts put him on puberty
blockers put them on crosstalk's
hormones and then this girl comes in and
says that's not what's really going on
challenges the narrative really good
interview if i do say so myself all
right next up
[Music]
oh the woke commercials
[Music]
guess a courtroom
[Music]
he's the judge but you thought he wasn't
the judge
let's talk about the look so we can see
beyond it
it's always proctoring gamble we're
always always proctor and gamble it's
funny that the producers mentioned this
the woke commercials thing because
it was for it was my producer ben davies
said michael i saw these commercials
over the weekend you have to see them i
want to see if you can guess
what the product is that they're selling
because really all they're selling is
wokeness and political correctness but
they've now buried the actual product so
far you probably can't even guess what
it is so i said okay so we'd do one of
these i figured just be a little one-off
thing throw it up on the channel see if
people like it
and they completely took off
people would stop me on the street say
michael i love and i'm waiting for them
to say the michael knowles show maybe
they say verdict maybe they say pray or
you maybe they say
the blank book the book with the word no
they would stop me and they'd say i love
your woke commercials and i thought well
what i'm just reacting to these things
that people are seeing on tv why is that
resonating why i now i now get why it's
resonating i think that's why the series
went so
viral and why people still like it is
because we realize hold on as much as i
don't like hillary much as i don't like
nancy pelosi or andrew cuomo or biden or
whoever those guys are not my only
problem they might not even be my
primary problem i'm talking about disney
i'm talking about
coca-cola i'm talking about nike i'm
talking these huge multinational
corporate i'm talking about the gigantic
studios that have basically sold out our
country to china and sold out our
culture to china those guys are in many
ways a bigger problem we've got to take
them on in the political fight next up
maybe this one will be clear
the drinking game i love it
so leviticus 1928 says no tattoos
well
yeah now i can't help but notice
got a little ink there that's just
that's henna that's fake i do that i
redo that every morning before i come
out it's a strange tattoo because it's
it's an ancient christian symbol like
it's oh is that what it is i don't know
if you know the uh i thought it was
japanese for water
i love the drinking game
pretty much any drinking game but but
that one too i don't know the rules to
that one
that's this is called the yes or no
drinking i still don't really know the
rules i pretty much just drink after
every question
but i do enjoy doing it it's like a good
version of cards against humanity i hate
cards against humanity i hate it i hate
it i know millennials love it and it's
just unbearable and it's not even really
a game that's a fun little uh surprise
from the folks at cards against my real
favorite part of the game is that they
they make me a martini sometimes at 10
in the morning and very often it's
pretty good the way you make a martini
of course
you pour the gin while staring at a
bottle of vermouth from across the room
blue cheese olives delicious a very dry
arid barren desiccated veritable dust
bowl of a martini next one
get pumped for the polls if joe biden
wants my vote then he better pick animal
crossing as his vice president joe biden
you know i was a pioneer i was a true
i'm one of the founding fathers of the
genre of reacting to tick-tock videos i
am unintentionally i don't you know i've
looked at tik tok for a total of
probably 15 minutes i was sitting there
with my wife and we wanted to see what
all the fuss was about and it's just
like pure crack and you if you don't
pull yourself out of it you'll just get
sucked into tick tock forever i'll tell
you it
it's very important to bring this kind
of weird creepy content from tick tock
to twitter because the average age of a
tick tock user
is like 12 or something that's not the
real number but it's significantly lower
than the average age of a twitter user
or certainly of a facebook user so
you're talking about an extremely
influential platform where normal grown
people just have no idea what's actually
going on so i was glad we were able to
do that i think that's why the tick tock
stuff did go viral just like this is
going to go viral because this is this
is some extremely edgy
reaction
it's content reacting to reactions of
content that sometimes reacts to things
and it will be like a taco inside a taco
within a taco bell that's inside a kfc
within this as i react to my 1000th
episode thank you to all of you who made
that possible 1 000 episodes we look
forward to a thousand more and i and i
on the 2000th episode cannot wait to
look back and reflect on my reflection
from the 1000th episode on all of my
reactions to reflections from the many
years before that thank you and see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you